BRET BAIER.
>> Bret: THANKS, GREG.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
WITHIN THE PAST 30 MENTION
AUTHORITIES IN CHICAGO
REPORTED ACTIVE SHOOTER ON
SOUTH SIDE HOSPITAL.
NOW THEY SAY SEVERAL PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN WOUNDED IN THAT
SHOOTING.
A LIST REPORTEDLY INCLUDING
A POLICE OFFICER AND A
SUSPECT AT THIS HOUR.
SENIOR CORRESPONDENT MIKE
TOBIN HAS THE LATEST
BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT FROM
THE SCENE, GOOD EVENING,
MIKE.
GOOD EVENING, BRET.
WE HAVE CONFIRMATION THROUGH
MERCY HOSPITAL THE SHOOTING
IS OVER.
THERE WAS A POLICE OFFICER
SCOURING THE HALLWAYS HERE
AT MERCY HOSPITAL END
OCCASION THAT THEY FELT THE
THREAT WAS NOT ALLEVIATED
BUT NOW WE HAVE THAT
CONFIRMATION THROUGH THE
HOSPITAL THAT THE INCIDENT
HERE IS OVER.
CONFIRMED THROUGH ANTHONY,
THE CHICAGO POLICE SPOKESMAN
ONE POLICE OFFICER HAS BEEN
SHOT.
HE IS IN CRITICAL CONDITION.
HE HAS BEEN TRANSFERRED TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF HOSPITAL
MEDICAL CENTER.
WE ARE AWAITING AN UPDATE
FROM HIM.
A POSSIBLE SUSPECT HAS BEEN
SHOT.
SCANNER TRAFFIC SAYS THAT
SUSPECT WAS SHOT IN THE
FACE.
NOT CONFIRMED THROUGH
OFFICIAL CHANNELS.
ACCOUNTS TWO PEOPLE DEAD AND
CHICAGO TRIBUNE REPORTS LESS
THAN SIX.
AGAIN, THAT'S NOT THROUGH
OFFICIAL CHANNELS.
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR THAT
INFORMATION TO BE BOILED
DOWN.
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
WITNESSES IS THAT THE GUNMAN
FOCUSED PARTICULARLY ON
WOMAN -- ONE WOMAN STANDING
OVER HER IN A PARKING LOT
DISCHARGING MULTIPLE SHOTS
IN HER DIRECTION U REALLY A
POINT BLANK RANGE I SHOULD
SAY.
THAT BEING SAID, WE DON'T
KNOW IF THIS WAS MOTIVATED
BY A DOMESTIC DISPUTE.
IF THIS SADLY WOULD FIT THE
PATTERN THAT WE HAVE BECOME
ACCUSTOMED TO WITH THESE
MASS SHOOTINGS OR PART OF
THE VIOLENCE HAVE YOU HEARD
SO MUCH ABOUT PLAYING
SO MUCH ABOUT PLAGUNG
SO MUCH ABOUT PLAGUING THE
CITY OF COSHOCTON.
WE ARE ON THE SOUTH SIDE OF
THE CITY RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN'T MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS RIGHT NOW THERE
WERE 21 SHOOTINGS OVER THE
WEEKEND HERE IN THE CITY OF
CHICAGO.
SO, GUN VIOLENCE IS STILL
VERY MUCH A PROBLEM HERE
WE'RE WAITING ON MORE
DETAILS.
THROUGH OFFICIALS HERE THE
THREAT IS ALLEVIATED AND THE
SHOOTING SITUATION IS NOW
OVER.
BRET?
>> Bret: 21 SHOOTINGS OVER